السلام عليكم ليش دولار اليوم هذه الجمله
هي الاكثر تداولا هنا في الاسواق العراقيه
حيث لا يكاد يمر يوم الا وارتفع معه سعر
الصرف
وتزايدت المخاوف من تكرار سيناري ينهيار
العمله اللبنانيه في العراق
في الاداره العراقيه التعاون مع الفدرالي
الامريكي لحل الازمه لان المتضرر صراحه
التاجره الضرر الفقير الضرر المستهلك
الضرر
كل
الامور في بغداد الان واقفه بسبب ارتفاع
الدولار الغير طبيعي
تسبب لهم بمشاكل ماليه
كلها اللحوم عندنا الدجاج كله تركي ايراني
كله صاعد يعني
الدولار
واحنا جاي نعيش بازمه والله يستر من
القاعده انه يعني مثل الدول الجوار مثلا
لبنان شلون صار
الدولار الدولار
كنت بصالح البنك المركزي وبصالح الاقتصاد
لترصين اكثر القرار حضيه بغطاء كامل من
تلاف اداره الدوله ومن الاطار التنسيقي
واا تقديري اي الخطوات التي اتخذتها
الحكومه خطوات جريئه وقويه وفاعله
وستؤثر بشكل سريع همم يعني على مستوى
السوق في اعاده التوازن الى سعر العمله
القديمه
وخسارته نحو عشره بالمئه من قيمه الدينار
شكل تحديا حقيقيا لحكومه السوداني لانه
يمص الطبقات الفقيره بشكل مباشر الامر
الذي ينذر بتحركات شعبيه على مستوى الشارع
اذا ما استمرت قيمه الدولار بالسعودي امام
الدينار بالتسامح مع اقاله محافظ البنك
المركزي شهده الاسواق الماليه انخفاض
النسبيا في اسعار صرف الدولار امام
الدينار لكن يبقى سؤال هنا هل سيستمر هذا
الانخفاض ام سيكون بشكل مؤقت سامر كويتي
العربيه بغداد